ich spiele heute das Horrorspiel five
nights at Freddys auf der derzeit besten
Virtual Reality Brille der
Welt ich hatte noch nie so viel Angst
vor einem Youtube
Video ach du scheiße ach du
scheiße
hi ach du scheiße das ist ja genauso wie
das auf dem
PC oh mein Gott kann ich jetzt auch hier
in die Gänge gucken oder was ach du
scheiße habe ich verloren wir starten
noch mal von vorne okay wir haben hier
unseren Monitor und können so checken
wer wo ist die drei Idioten sind auf
jeden Fall noch in ihrem ursprungsraum
Cam 1b alles in Ordnung ist niemand hier
vorne keiner hier vorne keiner hier
vorne ach das Ding bewegt sich nur wegen
dem Helikopter da
oben da ist auf jeden Fall auch niemand
das ist aber keiner oder C 2a niemand
ist aber ein bisschen dunkel hier direkt
neben uns auch nichts direkt hier nichts
da warum kommen jetzt solche Sounds
camera dis das ist nicht
[Musik]
wahr ist niemand7 niemand wir schauen
sind alle noch da nein einer ist weg wo
bist du er steht schon da er ist schon
zwei Räume wir sind da gerade mal eine
Stunde drin was soll das Bruder Mann
Arschloch kann ich hier noch mehr Sachen
nehmen Mann e guck mal die anderen
beiden sind Ehrenmänner beide noch da
mashallah beide sitzen hier vorne in
ihem ursprungsraum ihr macht's richtig
und
du Gang weiter ich k KZ aber
weg
nur noch einer da keiner einer da ist
einer das ist nicht
de das ist nicht dein Ernst wir schauen
mal wer noch hinten ist guck mal
der der Ehrenmann ist da vorne noch C7
keiner C 6 disaed sehr gut Cam 4 keiner
hier ist keiner okay direkt neben uns
ist niemand hier ist
keiner ist das
einer ich R schon wieder alles auf ja ne
ne ne ich schau jetzt mal ganz kurz ob
hierer
ist bitte nicht
okay Licht aus da vorne ist keiner da
ist keiner wir schauen mal ganz hinten
in den Raum einer ist immer noch da der
absolute Ehrenmann ist noch vor Ort C
1b da hat sich gerade einer wegbewegt
ach du scheiße hier ist
keiner hier ist keiner du kleiner
Bastard du kleiner Bastard geh zurück
Beispiel an ihm er ist absoluter
Ehrenmann er cht da vorne ch einfach
hier
hier hier ist keiner rechts auch keiner
links keiner links keiner Cam 3 ist der
okay wissen wir schon ist ein kleiner
31er K 1c keiner Cam 5 keiner hier
keiner absoluter
Ehrenmann Donal Duck kan vielleicht B
verpissen oh mein Gott ich habe noch 9%
aber wir sind schon bei 4 Uhr nachts das
heißt nur noch 2 Stunden sollten wir
eventuell packen ka absoluter ehremann
schreib mir mal bitte in die Kommentare
wer das ist dieser Typ ich werde ih
Heiratsantrag machen er bleibt ganz
hinten wie ein absoluter Bruder
ich h
Schritte sag nicht er ist hier sag nicht
er ist hier er ist nicht hier Tür besser
mal zu er ist nämlich laut diesem Plan
direkt links neben mir rechts neben mir
ist niemand ausgefallen ich Kön kotzen
ich Kön kotzen du bist es du bist mein
Freund mit DIR will ich mein Leben
verbringen aber nicht mit euch anderen
mir komplett egal wie schnell es jetzt
leer geht ich hoffe einfach dass die 0%
erst erreicht sind wenn hier 6 Uhr ist
weil wir müssen es bis 6 Uhr schaffen
Freunde bis 6 Uhr müssen wir überleben
dann haben wir es geschafft dann haben
wir es geschafft weiter geht es auch
nicht mehr heute weiter kann ich nicht
mehr ich kann das ich bin jetzt schon
voll am schwitz ich hab ein neues
T-Shirt gekauft ich habe ein neues
T-Shirt gekauft und jetzt ist voll mit
Schweiz ich hasse Horrorspiele ich hasse
Achterbahn Horrorspiele Horrorfilme
warum tut man sich Sachen an die
obviously nicht geil sind wo man
schwitzt wo es einem scheiße geht h er
ist immer noch da 6% komm F
[Musik]
Scheiße ein Preis
chilliger Raum auch hier mit den Dingern
klasse super aber okay nehme ich was ist
da
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
drin ein Bier menschlich gesind ziemlich
abstoßen Tag Nummer 2 meine Damen und
Herren nein nein nein Schoner Weg wie
kann das denn sein wir sind uh er ist
schon wieder
weg wie kann das sein sag jetzt nicht wo
bist
du camera disa wo bist du camera
disabled der Typ kann jetzt nicht schon
direkt bei mir sein oder C 2a Cam 3 ist
nicht Cam 1 c ist nicht C 5 ist er nicht
1 1b
istter wo seid ihr wo ist er
Cam
kamer
mein ist ich krieg Herz wirklich er ist
ein Ehrenmann absolut bester
Typ er ist cool den Heirat der wird auch
in der zweiten Nacht sich nämlich nicht
verpiseln der ist ein Bruder F keiner
ein C keiner drei keiner 2a keiner
zwei okay okay okay okay what do mate
oh mein Gott wer er den den habe ich
noch nie
gesehen oh mein Gott der sieht
ausan ach du kleiner Hoh es wirklich so
einine ich diese Scheiße Spiel disable
warum haben meine Videos so viele
Aufrufe wenn ich dieses Spiel spiele ich
weiß hey Laa wir finden es total cool
wenn du dir Sorgen machst erst ein
Bruder er ist ein Bruder er denkt sich
okay
erstes und letztes Mal dass ich ein
Horrorspiel in Virtual Reality gespielt
habe